what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so getting into armor hunters again it's
been a little you know been a few weeks
or so since we covered some value comic
stuff and I feel like Robert Vendetti is
doing an amazing job with regards to you
know to this EXO Medawar story we're
really kind of like the valiant comic
story because this involves quite a few
characters but armor hunters is stellar
in terms of how it unfolds and what it
all involves and the reason why is
because of the fact that up into this
point in the EXO Manowar retelling most
of the emphasis has been on Eric of
Dacia in terms of how he functions on
earth which is to say the fact that he's
basically time this place you know again
for those of you guys who were just kind
of catching up he was a guy he was
essentially kidnapped from the
fifth-century
kevin's a slave aboard an alien ship and
then you know finally managed to escape
by capturing the EXO Man O'War armor to
arrive on earth only to find out that
because of how fast the ship was
traveling two thousand years had
basically passed and you know on earth
in terms of him only you know aging by
ten years 15 years something like that
so because of the fact that the ship was
travelling faster than light and so
because of that arriving back on earth
meant that he was basically
time-displaced
along with the exo-armor he was trying
to restore his own society to vist
aghast and he had really just kind of
been struggling ever since now of course
with some of the more modern stories
that we've seen a really some of the
more recent stories he's gotten kind of
been stepping into the realm of
understanding that the world is vastly
different than the one that he's used to
and he basically can't just restore the
visigoth territory because that
territory of the world doesn't exist
anymore what used to be Rome is now
partially Rome and a whole bunch of
other countries that have formed their
own governments and so on and so forth
and so it's not as simple as just kind
of walking into somebody's backyard
planting a flag and saying I claim this
land in the name of the Visigoths
doesn't work that way anymore and so
it's been kind of cool to see his
character evolve in his character grow
but not a lot of credence has been given
to the exosuit of armor only insofar
that it's basically just kind of like a
suit that allows him to achieve
incredible feats and that's really been
about it the cool thing about armor
hunters is that it gives us this
entirely different perspective about the
suit and that's kind of cool because the
suit has largely been ambiguous the only
thing we knew about it was that the suit
was basically held by the vine race and
the vine worshipped it but what really
kind of goes on here is this idea that
the vine didn't even really know what it
was about their belief system regarding
the suit was as much legend as it was
just kind of filling in the holes of
questions they didn't have the answer to
and so again you know with regards to
armor hunters we basically take off with
a hunter
themselves arriving on earth and the
reason why is because of the fact that
the armored hunters are essentially an
extraterrestrial race of quite literally
exo-armor hunters what we'll find out on
this story again there's a lot that goes
into the nature of the armor themselves
but Malcolm the you know the guy that we
saw basically and freely two armored
hunters he was actually a member of the
armored hunters themselves the issue
with this is that he was actually
infected by the armor by the exosuit and
the result was that he was basically
cast out considered a pariah by the
armor hunters and they in turn went
after him now again we'll find out why
here in a minute
but the weight of the armor hunters are
formed is really more of benefit in
terms of how their team how their team
makeup is formed what roles they play so
on and so forth and so you basically
have their tech guy over there tech
thing more or less which comes in the
form of helix and helix is basically
just like pure data energy kind of a
given physical form which kind of allows
helix to jump in and out of computer
systems and so on and so forth and
they'll invade normal human host and
kind of corrupt their biological
structure and so on but the entire basis
behind them being here is to essentially
find the exosuit itself now of course
what this shows us is that they are
tracking the suits by way of some kind
of signal that's left behind by the suit
itself essentially following breadcrumbs
and because of the fact that XO Man
O'War because of the fact that even in
different territories around the world
these individuals are tracking down the
various locations that eric has been in
in order to find him and then eliminate
him take the suit for themselves now of
course what we also end up finding out
is that the Russians are basically
trying to duplicate the exosuit of armor
and this is very alarming to the armor
hunters and the reason why is because of
the fact that reporting back to the guy
who's basically running the show primary
rebo what we end up finding out here is
that the suit itself as far as they're
concerned is effectively sentient in the
sense that the suit basically goes
around and it takes over a host now
again this is really kind of ironic
because we never really viewed it that
way we just kind of viewed it as just a
suit that a person was able to wear and
that was really it not only that up
until this point we only ever thought
there was one exosuit what Malcolm
showed us is that there's more than one
there are multiple EXO suits and each
one basically carries out its own role
and it's Oprah film it now of course
switching over to Eric himself he's
basically grabbed by the US military for
the purpose of essentially trying to
figure out what's going on with these
armor hunters of course the idea to the
armor hunters show
they basically incapacitated the
Russians took over their base it's a
very concerning issue for the u.s. just
because of the fact that this base of
the Russians was so heavily guarded and
so if the armored hunters were able to
just break in access the information on
these various suits that they were
developing that were designed to copy
the exosuits
then this poses a legitimate threat for
the u.s. because what it means if the
armored hunters can break in to their
various bases as well and so what we end
up doing is it basically pick up with
you know really with with primary rebo
speaking directly to miro again this
extraterrestrial organization that's
designed to essentially observe various
threats outside the planet earth and to
assess whether or not they're a danger
to the earth proper and what primary
role really says here is look you guys
have a choice either you can hand over
whoever it is that's wearing the you
know the exosuit and be allowed to live
or we will begin the process of killing
you all and this is kind of funny
because what Venditti is basically doing
is presenting the scenario of what
happens when an overwhelming force
approaches apply the earth and how the
governments respond what will humanity
do in this instance a primary rebo
provides this insane display of power in
order to show humanity what it is that
they're dealing with in terms of primary
and the armor hunters being here to
collect the exosuit and because of the
fact that the Secretary of Defense to
the upper brass in the US government
basically say we are not handing over
the suit because it's such a strong
weapon in return primary rebo basically
dispatches other ship ginger to send a
demonstration of their power more or
less and in doing so what they do is
they obliterate the entirety of mexico
city now again this is kind of crazy and
the reason why is because readers see
these kind of scenarios all the time in
the sense of it's like well we're not
going to give up we're not going to quit
we're going to fight until the bitter
end but this usually comes from the
stance of like superheroes right like
spider-man will fight until the bitter
end Captain America will fight into the
bitter end
when it comes to the military when it
comes to like US government's and so on
and so forth clear loyalty is to the
people or at least it should be and so
the idea is that if an overwhelming
force appears and basically says we're
going to wipe a city off the map if you
do not do what we tell you to do then
the question becomes do they give in
does the US military give in and this
presents a scenario where the US
military basically prizes weapons over
the lives of their citizens which is
kind of ironic because all of it is
really just designed for the purpose of
maintaining defense I mean the oh the
advance
of weaponry the advancement of
technology it's all for like the descent
of any one particular territory any one
particular nation but of what use is the
defense of the nation if everyone there
is dead and so that's kind of the irony
of the situation is ended he's giving it
to us because it's really like neo these
guys these armor hunters are basically
dispatching technology that allows them
to wipe cities off the map you know what
happens if they don't point their guns
at Mexico City and they instead point
their guns at Washington DC what's the
government going to do so because this
the response at least from exo himself
is to basically kind of jump into the
frame and find a way to bring these guys
down now of course with the idea that
they're trying to secure the armor
there's also some measure of honor in
combat among the armor hunters
themselves and what I mean by that is it
would be entirely possible for them to
just kind of obliterate you know cities
all over the place and really just kind
of cleanse the earth but they choose not
to and the reason why is because of the
faculty armor hunters also realize that
there's a difference between showing a
display of force as opposed to just
cleansing the entirety of the earth
why kill billions of people if you don't
have to they basically wiped out Mexico
City and say this is the kind of
destruction that we're capable of and
the US government still says no well
then you simply respond by going in and
just taking it just saying okay fine
then we'll take it we're not going to
obliterate the entirety of your planet
we're just going to obliterate you
because you're the one that's causing a
problem so again they basically
dispatched their own hounds down to the
surface which is kind of cool because it
shows us that it's a multi-faceted
effort to basically grab these armors
but it also shows us that these guys in
particular these armor hunters are
experienced in what it is that they're
dealing they fought a multitude of
different species a multitude of
different governments across a multitude
of different worlds and so they're
really prepared for virtually any kind
of race and whatever that race is
capable of now in terms of humanity's
response to this what this does is
basically begin bringing in unity now
again we had talked about unity with
regards to really others their first
major story arc and that was really
values version of The Avengers and in a
lot of ways unity itself was kind of
better than the Avengers you know in
terms of the team's makeup in terms of
whether different members of the team
were capable of for example one of the
more notable characters and one who will
play a pretty major role in a story is
live wire and live wire has the ability
to basically access any and all
communications or technological systems
that exist she literally has the psychic
power to access computer systems that's
not a power that you see consistently in
coming books but in valiant this
character livewire is front and center
and it makes her a very potent character
for the story and of course we'll
actually find out why now with regards
to bloodshot he's really more of valiant
version of an antihero
and you see a lot of those in comic
books you know that's really just
because of the Dark Knight Returns
and how that made Batman darker and
broody here and so really what it did is
it introduced the idea of anti-heroes
being more prominent with regards to
bloodshot he's one of these guys where
his memories just constantly wiped he
doesn't really know who he is doesn't
really know what's going on with him but
he has nanites so he's almost like half
machine half man insofar as of the
nanites allowing to heal but he's also a
highly trained mercenary and killer in a
lot of different ways and so again he's
kind of like the valiant universe
weapons expert like the one guy that you
would expect to be the most capable in
terms of like combat and weapons use and
the whole nine yards the fact remains
here that these different members of the
unity team had been brought here for the
purpose of basically trying to figure
out how to respond to the armor hunters
themselves now with regards to the
actual exosuit this is when we basically
learned that meat and potatoes behind
what it is with this particular guy
mouth on this guy that we saw in free
allude armor hunters the reason why he
looks the way he does is it because it's
a different type of armor you know of
exosuit it's because of the fact that
he's bonding with the suit the suit is
basically taking over him and that's
what we end up learning here that is not
like you know the valiant equivalent of
an Iron Man so that's the indication
that have always been given to us that's
what seemed to be going on here instead
what van did he does is he kind of
yanked the rug out from under us and
says actually it's not really an Iron
Man like suit instead this suit is
sentient
this suit is alive and basically what
happened is it bonds with its host the
idea of at allowing excellent Man O'War
to gain the abilities that he has and to
do the kind of things that he can do is
that under normal circumstances the suit
keeps the host protected so that when
the transformation process begins the
host will not lose its life and so the
result is that eventually the host in
this circumstance Malcolm will begin to
become the suit the suit will basically
bond with him on the genetic level now
what happens after that we don't know
with any real measure of certainty but
somewhere along the line those
individuals who were bonded with the
suit basically become bad guys they
become villains and that's the
motivation behind the are
Hunter's from their perspective the
suits are inherently evil the suits are
organic they're sentient they take over
host and the hosts become corrupted and
they become villainous they raise entire
worlds and move on to the next one
beyond our hunters are basically
stepping up you're saying even if you
don't know it EXO Manowar this suit is
going to bond with you you're going to
become a bad guy you're going to destroy
entire civilizations and cultures we're
here to stop you before that ever
becomes the case now what makes things a
little bit different with regards to
Eric is that the suit is not bonding
with him now the indication is given
here by Venditti is that because of the
fact that during the Unity storyline we
basically saw livewire become a host for
the EXO Man O'War suit and then begin
the process of controlling it that it
seems as though she's basically stemmed
it away from its normal role of taking
over host and instead it's now just a
suit that can be worn by a person and so
because of that it really seems as
though the idea of the suit corrupting
and taking over EXO Manowar is no longer
the case anymore and so because of the
fact that these various organisms have
been dispatched by the armor hunters
they've been attacking various cities
all over the world you know ideally this
city is that excellent man o'war has
visited what this is is really just kind
of like a call to arms from everyone now
of course this would take some
particular toll on Eric and the reason
why is because of the fact that his you
know I guess temporary home you know
where the vista Goths were allowed to
set up residence until they can actually
find you know a tried and true nation
for themselves a lot of their number are
basically attacked and reduced to the
point of almost near extinction now of
course this is really rather than to be
kind of coming along and say look you
know that this aghast has just kind of
been living in people's backyards for a
while even houseguest for quite some
time
it's basically time to thin their her to
reduce their number down so that we can
basically have kind of like a fresh
start for Erica Basya and his wife slash
girlfriend sana and so because of that
would it really only be the two of them
left they can now just kind of go
forward and set up a life for themselves
so again the fact remains here with this
attack coming from the armor hunters
themselves the question becomes can
humanity respond adequately can humanity
come up with a plan of their own in
order to basically save themselves as
well as fend off against the armor
hunters now the funny thing about this
is that all these different attacks that
are coming from the armor hunters are
really just classic forms of warfare
right as a classic way to defeat your
enemy you can do it in a couple
different ways there is a war of
attrition where you just
keeps sending an insane amount of
numbers you can capitalize on the
weaknesses of your existing enemy I mean
all that stuff is classic warfare Sun
Tzu art of war if different things like
that and you see a play out in almost
every form of media where war takes
place you know you see that kind of
scenario you see this scenario playing
out time and time again go into cities
conquer those cities weaken humanity
force them to fight a war on two fronts
battle the enemy while taking care of
their sick stretch their numbers out
it's a classic example of conflict you
know a classic example of how to wage a
war and so because of everything that's
happened because of the fact that so
many of his own people have died despite
all his best efforts and all the things
that he's gone through to keep them
alive
Erik effectively abandons his role as XO
man of war he simply walks away from the
suit and so because of this Colonel
Capshaw you know kind of like the
military liaison that XO Man O'War
previously worked with the decision is
made that if Erik is going to give up
the exosuit that's fine but the conflict
is going to be fought on her terms now
this is absolute genius and I love the
way that Robert VIN did he did this
because of the fact that humanity is
just experiencing these crushing blows
and these crushing defeats in all these
different cities ultimately the
indication is given here that humanity
just gives up they literally say okay
part like capture OGG tells primary rear
oh look we quit you've crushed us too
far we cannot stand against the forces
that you have at your disposal that you
have at your command and we're sending
in the suit of armor you can have the
suit do with it as you want to what we
end up learning is that inside this suit
is livewire now again this is awesome
because remember there in ginger and
ginger is just this giant mechanized
suit it's a mechanized computerized suit
live wire controls computers live wire
takes control of ginger and it's the
coolest thing because what she
immediately does is just say okay fine
we're just going to crash this thing
like we're going to set it on
self-destruct and we're going to crash
this thing into the ground we're going
to bring it crashing down around
everybody and that's exactly what
initially happens the problem with this
is that I guess the best way I can put
it you know relative mass to the length
of a fall you know let's say for example
you just fell backwards and you hit the
ground it would hurt but you probably
wouldn't die even if you hit your head
you probably wouldn't die I mean you
might have some brain damage depending
on how hard your brain hits your head
but if I drop you from 500 feet you'll
die like
we'll hit the ground and you will die
with this whole idea of ginger it's the
same way you know ginger falling from
the altitude that it was at relative to
its size how durable it is how strong it
is hitting the ground wasn't necessarily
like falling you know 500 feet but it
was certainly like falling 7 feet and so
it does some damage to the suit but it
doesn't destroy it in its entirety and
so because that it basically initiates a
hard reboot and begins the process of
carry out the orders of primary rebo to
just obliterate everything around it now
again the cool thing about this is that
primary rebo is pulling no punches and
the reason why is pulling no punches
here is because of the fact that he's
tired of being an armor hunter and
that's one of the cool things that were
given about his character we're not
given a lot of character development
with these guys we're given some but the
character development that we are given
especially the primary rebo is that he
is tired of being an armor hunter he's
tired of the great hunt he wants to
finish this he wants to call it a day
and he wants to leave not only that this
mission is a little personal than we
would expect it to be and the reason why
is because of the fact that now them was
one of their own and so even if it's
only for the purpose of killing him and
then retrieving his body and giving him
an honorable burial reba wants to see
this whole mission through now this is
the cool thing because the unity team
are pushed to the absolute limit on a
normal circumstances we would say well
then we'll just have in a live wire
access ginger and then try the entire
system all over again instead what's
happening here is that you basically
have ginger forming a shield around
itself and then it's got it's also got
these small probes that are just racing
through destroying everything in sight
and so because of the fact that these
are computerized probes and because of
the fact that live wire is trying to
access them they don't have a high month
they all function with their own
enclosed systems now the reason why this
matters is because of the fact that this
is yet another example of entities
showing us how the armor hunters are
prepared for virtually everything I
wouldn't go as far as to say the armor
hunters had designed these you know
small little probes for the purpose of
just avoiding someone like livewire
who's a technopath and can access any
and all forms of technology using your
mind but the purpose is still served and
the purpose still works you know
ultimately it keeps still live wire from
being able to function in her full
capacity and the result is that he
manages kind of left to do what they can
when they can and evacuate as many
places as they can so ultimately what
ends up happening here is we have read
on his exo-armor and
we say look you know if this is what it
takes in order to pull this off and this
is what it takes is me just killing this
guy kind of stepping up you know playing
the role of the hero one more time
that's exactly what he does it was
really kind of like a very is a very
heroic scenario for 4x it was a very
heroic instance of his characters kind
of jumping in taking on the role that
he's meant to be and being a hero and so
ultimately this leads to a direct
physical conflict between primary rivo
and Eric and kind of like this last
battle to determine the fate of the
planet so it's really kind of cool now
what this does is this brings in you
know brings in the shop relief the
nature of the armor hunters in terms of
how they kill individuals who have the
exosuits
and the reason why is because of the
fact that the exosuits are virtually
indestructible when it comes to
traditional arms when it comes to like
conventional warfare of any kind and
what the armor hunters do is they use
spheres that basically disrupt the
connection between the host and the suit
itself and because this connection is
disrupted it's basically like grabbing
another sphere and then killing the host
so they don't really kill the suit the
suit can't literally be destroyed all
you can do is kill the host that the
suits using to replicate itself and
because of the fact that the suit can't
replicate dead tissue because I can't
feed on dead tissue and duplicate that
ultimately what isn't happening as a
suit just kind of sits there and just
waits for somebody else to come along
and somebody else to access it now what
they usually end up doing is they
usually end up just kind of like
grabbing a suit and then taking a suit
putting it in containment and calling it
a day so nobody else can access it but
ultimately the entirety of the armor
hunters are basically defeated by the
forces of unity so of course again it's
one of these things for unity
effectively saves the day but again what
this does is it's more or less kind of
like a soft reboot for the character of
XO Man O'War and that's usually what
happens you know you usually give us you
know value will give us these smaller
stories it'll be designed to kind of
reshuffle things and set the stage for
the next line of storytelling really the
role of bits was to give us an idea of
what the exosuit actually his it was to
tell us what the exosuit is actually
like you know what his purpose is what
its form and function is and what it
actually does the other half of this was
to reduce the number of Visigoths so
that there was really only X so you know
Erica Basya and his wife Sanne and that
was really it you know and so again it
kind of gives us this idea that in the
future going for there will be more
emphasis on air consump emphasis on the
exosuit more in
on as well as a hero as well as what
role he'll play in unity as part of the
valiant universe but with that being
said guys if you are new here to come
let's explain make sure you hit the sub
button to become part of the war if you
guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
there
you